These albatross are the modern family of the
animal kingdom.
This bird is female and so is this one.
They’re raising a nest full of babies together.
And yes, they’re lesbians.
Why do these females make a long-term commitment
to homosexuality?
Keep in mind that sexuality in the wild is
fluid - animals are not simply homo or hetero.
Not only do the vast majority of animal species
engage in a little same-sex foreplay and copulation,
there are many that exhibit something called
homosexual preference.
This refers to the selection of a same-sex
partner over an opposite-sex partner despite
the fact that opposite-sex partners are readily
available.
Along with birds, same-sex preference is also
common in mammals and even primates.
When these lesbian love birds require a sperm
donation, it’s never particularly difficult
for either of them to find a male who’s
interested in copulating, amirite ladies?.
Copulation in these albatross and in most
birds is not accomplished via the traditional
penis/vagina route.
There’s one general opening down there for
both waste and sexual products… called a
cloaca.
During sex, male and female albatrosses rub
their swollen cloacas together.
Sperm from the male bird’s testes swims
through the female’s cloacal opening and
to her ovaries.
And that’s that.
No cuddles for this casual couple because
the female is already flying home to her bae
and their unconventional family.
It seems that the lesbian albatross simply
prefer each others’ company.
Raising their offspring with the influence
of two mommies allows for the nest to be twice
as productive since both moms can lay eggs,
and they don’t argue over the bulk of their
domestic tasks.
Yeah! they just accomplish them without complaining.
While some albatrosses make partner switches
every season or few seasons, some albatross
females, like this couple, stay together for
decades.
A true testament that love is love.
If you want to see more copulation creations,
check out this Wild Sex playlist!
Let us know in the comments what animal sex
stories you want to see.
If you want more stories right now, grab a
copy of the book Wild Sex, written by me,
Dr. Carin Bondar.
Thanks for watching and make sure to subscribe!